got a bit of breaking news and it
relates to some strikes for Heathrow
Airport security guards and the United
Union has said that last Stitch talks
have failed uh and that strikes will go
ahead on Friday uh and uh they'll last
for 10 days around 1 400 uh unite
members will be walking out for those 10
days which uh therefore will cross over
a lot of Easter weekend uh and this does
in particular relate to Terminal 5 at
Heathrow which is operated by British
Airways predominantly and some other
campus security guards who across all of
the airport uh unites that the strikes
will cause disruption to flight however
Heathrow said it has contingency plans
to deal with the industrial action